Oh Lord, how many are my foes.
Many are rising against me.
Many are saying of my soul, there is no salvation for Him in God.
But You, O Lord, are a shield about me, my glory, and the lifter of my head.
I cried aloud to the Lord, and He answered me from His holy hill.
I laid down and slept.
I woke again, for the Lord sustained me.
I will not be afraid of many thousands of people who have set themselves against me all around.
Arise, O Lord, save me, O my God, for You strike all my enemies on the cheek.
You break the teeth of the wicked.
Salvation belongs to the Lord.
Your blessing be on Your people.
The word of the Lord.
When I was a kid, my parents had one of these baby first books.
I don't know if you've seen one of those.
You know, when I took my first steps and that kind of thing and first words.
And I think my first words were like a lot of children's mama.
And my second word was crystal.
And it wasn't because we had a family member named Crystal.
It's because I had learned that I liked fast food pretty early on.
And so we'd go through the drive-through.
So that was my next word.
And of course, neither one of those things was the actual first thing that came out of my
mouth.
Like you probably, I guess, I guess it's true of all of us.
Yeah, the first thing that came out of my mouth was like a primal scream at the hospital.
And it was followed by much crying after that.
And for months after that, my communication style didn't change much.
You know, I cried.
And I cried until my needs were met.
So we all come into this world crying out, crying out for food or crying out for comfort.
And we cry out until that need is satisfied.
And perhaps it's not then surprising that the first prayer in this prayer book called
the Psalms is a cry for help.
It's the first words that we're praying together as God's people here as we pray
the book of Psalms.
Now it's more than a cry for help, but it is certainly that.
And the cry for help in Psalm 3 can be summarized by the words that we just read
in verse 7, save me, oh my God.
It's cry for salvation.
Now nobody wants to experience the kinds of hardship that would cause you or
provoke you to cry out in this way.
And we'll see just how bad it gets here in just a minute.
But it is better to have troubles drive you to God than to have a life of ease
without him.
Right? So troubles have a way of pointing us in the direction of where we need to
be looking in the first place.
And that is to the Lord.
I mean, when you read the gospels, you see that time and time again,
people come to Jesus for various reasons.
But top of the list is they have a need.
And so they bring that need to Jesus.
And then in Jesus, often they find that he is far greater than the Savior
that they were looking for.
All right? They wanted salvation from whatever their temporary trouble was.
But he was a far greater Savior who came to bring about a far greater salvation.
But it was a need that provoked them to seek him out in the first place.
One time, a local university professor came to our church in England.
And it was where I was pastoring at the time.
And she was a...
I didn't know all of this at the time, but she was a senior lecturer in neuroscience
at the local hospital.
She had had dozens of papers published in international journals.
And she had been a decided atheist for many, many years.
But when she came to the church, she was very open.
She said, I want to know more about the Christian faith.
And she let us know a little bit more about herself that years before,
a friend had given her a Bible.
And she had no interest in that Bible at the time.
But now she really wanted to know more.
And you could just tell, like she was really sincere and hungry to find out more.
And so you have to wonder, well, what happens to go from a decided atheist
to wanting to hear more about what Christianity is all about?
Despite her academic credentials, she had a personal hardship
that brought her to a place of crying out for help that was far beyond herself.
This crisis came into her life and she couldn't think her way out of it.
She couldn't work her way out of it.
And as she realized she needed help beyond herself and that this friend
at the center of the Bible, she said, well, maybe that's where I need to be looking.
And so she then sought out a church.
We came alongside her and she eventually came to the place of crying out to Christ himself
and having her life transformed by him.
Let me tell you, like hearing her begin that journey in prayer and then following
the Lord in baptism and continuing to grow as a sister in Christ was one of the most
joyful things that I have ever experienced.
And let me tell you, this this boy from Alabama didn't do anything
to intellectually convince her of the existence of God or the work of Christ
or any of that, but God providentially worked in her life and allowed her to go
through what she went through in a way that pointed her to himself.
And she came to a place of of knowing and resting in Jesus.
But it all began with that that hardship.
So need has a way of of humbling us and provoking out or provoking within us
a need to seek a savior from outside ourselves.
And when we come to Jesus, we find that our need was greater than our thought,
but he is a greater savior that we could imagine.
The way we come to him is through prayer.
Psalm three shows us what that kind of prayer looks like, whether or not
that's that's the first time you've prayed and you're just crying out for God to help.
If God, if you're out there, help me.
Or or you've you've known the Lord for many years and and need still has a way
of provoking us to then seek the Lord afresh.
We're told as the Psalm begins that it is a Psalm of David.
So you see that title there.
And this is the first of seventy three Psalms in the book of Psalms that are
attributed to David.
And we're told that it's connected to a time when he was fleeing from Absalom,
his son.
And so we'll find out a bit more about that in a minute.
But this is the problem that is driving him to the Lord.
So what we're going to do is we're going to look at the
problem that he's he's facing.
And then we're going to look at the prayer itself and how he prays.
And then we're going to finally see the kind of the outcome that he's expecting.
Like what's the what's the prospect that he is he's hoping for?
All right. So let's look at what this this problem is, this distress
that provokes David to seek out the Lord.
All right. So we're told he's fleeing from his son, Absalom.
So if you look in in the Old Testament, Second Samuel,
chapters 15 and 16, you can read that story.
And it's a really tragic situation.
So his own son has now gathered an army and he's he wants to seize power
and to take the throne.
And David has to flee for his life.
So he is he's not just facing enemies.
He's facing troubles within his own family.
He's been hunted down by his own son.
But notice how he describes his problem in the Psalms.
He talks about his enemies by talking about how numerous they are.
Oh, Lord, how many are my foes.
So it begins with Absalom.
You can read about how Absalom starts winning people's hearts
and bringing people over to his cause.
So this kind of growing opposition against David.
And now he's got this whole army ready.
And so he isn't just David isn't just facing opposition on one front,
but on many fronts.
I don't know if you've ever found yourself in that situation where it's
if it was just one issue I was dealing with right now, that'd be fine.
But it's all around me.
But that's David.
But they're not just many or numerous.
They are active as well.
So he says, many are rising against me.
Notice that language of rising.
So these aren't just people who exist to want him like Alstead.
He is actively being hunted down like they are.
They are pursuing him.
A full blown uprising is underway.
So they're active in their pursuit of him.
But also you have this third description of how they are scornfully.
He says, many are saying of my soul.
There is no salvation for him in God.
So the threat is, yes, physical.
You know, there's physical harm here and him like losing his is his throne
as kingdom.
But there's more than just a threat of physical harm here.
There they're they're taunting him in ways that can be like discouraging
demoralizing.
So there's mental and emotional and spiritual threat that is here as well.
There's no salvation for you in God.
They are saying.
And this might seem to some people like less important than like the physical
threat that is his life is under.
But that's that's not the case.
I don't know if you've ever come across the book, Man's Search for Meaning
by Victor Frankel.
He was an Austrian neuroscientist who went through the Holocaust
and he writes about his experience in concentration camps.
But he specifically talks about the power of hope in those particular
contexts.
And one of the ways he kind of expresses that is the kind of devastating
consequences of of hope being lost.
And he talks about how there are some people who were aiming and just
just knew they were going to be released by a certain date, like a certain holiday
or something like that.
And they were just convinced.
And so they were going through all this hardship, but they were moving
with that future hope in mind.
And once they passed that date, he describes, they just they gave up hope.
And there were many who, and since there's a people dying right after that
date they were aiming at.
So things that attack our sense of hope are no joke.
And that's especially the case when it comes to our hope in God.
And this is the kind of attack he's under.
Well, how might this apply?
Well, certainly you see this applying to Jesus.
And his his ministry right right from the beginning in the Gospels, you see
that Jesus faces enemies, but you didn't read about the kind of growing
hostility over time.
So his his enemies become more and more numerous and they become more
and more active in their hostility.
And they they taunt him as well.
So you you even go to the cross and what do you hear there in Matthew
chapter 27 as he hangs there on Looker's mock saying he saved others.
He cannot save himself.
He is the king of Israel.
So let him come now down from the cross and we will believe in him.
He trusts in God.
Let God deliver him now.
So they're mocking him.
Can you can you really save yourself?
Is God really going to save you?
Can also be applied to the church experiencing hostility.
In the history of the church, actually this this very psalm, Psalm
three has been used as a prayer for the persecuted church.
So you read the writings of the early church father Athanasius.
And he was writing to a friend and saying that in times of persecution,
when when the church is being persecuted, pray, Psalm three.
But you see examples of this kind of thing in the New Testament.
So Acts chapter four, the church is experiencing persecution there.
And they go to to Psalm two that we heard last week.
And they're they're praying the very words of Psalm two,
looking to the Lord as the one who who reigns over all things.
And so they're praying these psalms in times of persecution.
This certainly can help in that way.
And let this just be a time of reminding us.
We'll have to have a time of praying about this in a moment as well.
But there are estimated over three hundred and eighty
million Christians in the world today who are living in a place
where they are under active persecution in some kind of way or another,
where they are actively being oppressed and persecuted for their faith.
And that is not just churches out somewhere.
We are part of that same body.
Like we're members of that body that is being persecuted.
So this is a psalm for us as the persecuted body of Christ.
But we suffer as they suffer.
And so that we should be praying on their behalf to the Lord in the midst of their suffering.
But we all face personal hostility and hardship as well.
The psalm can help us with.
And we saw back in Ephesians six that Satan has more than one way of attack.
You know, whether it's an attack from from the enemy,
like spiritual attack or just our fallen nature,
you don't have to be running for your life like David to feel the same kind of fear
and despair that he believed or that he felt in himself.
And that kind of fear and despair can either drive us to the Lord or drive us to like
believe a lie to just trust in our feelings on that front.
You know, it could be a the attack that we feel could be like a lack of job security
or parenting struggles or waiting to get results from a biopsy or whatever it is.
And we we feel that viscerally in ourselves.
And the question is then like, what words are we going to believe?
Perhaps words even come into our own mind, like like are being spoken to David.
There is no salvation in God.
Words can be more deadly than arrows or nails,
attempting us to not believe in the goodness of God, turn away from him.
So the question is, where do we go with the fears that we face
when we're feeling this hostility? Where do we go when we are afraid?
Well, we see where we can go here.
But before we see that, notice what it says there, say, that repeated
a couple more times in the Psalm.
You see that throughout the book of Psalms.
Do you know what that means?
No, you don't.
Nobody knows what that means.
I certainly don't know what it means.
It could be a musical term that that's been suggested.
There's certainly musical terms there in Psalms.
It's been suggested that it could mean like to pause.
And that may very well be the case, but it's certainly a good idea to pause
and to think about what we're reading here.
And hey, when we're when we're fearful to just apply it here,
when we're fearful, it's good to pause
and to and to and to not just be led away by our feelings.
But just to let you know, that's what Salah means or doesn't mean.
So what does David do with his fear?
He prays and prays.
So notice the prayer that he prays and how he prays can give us some instruction
about how we respond in times of distress.
The first thing we see him doing is he he names his concerns.
So when David cries to the Lord, he doesn't just do so in a in a general way.
Now, I love this about many of the Psalms, like he gets very specific.
He talks, he lays these these very specific things before the Lord
that he is facing, asking God to take care of them.
So you you read in the New Testament places like Philippians chapter four,
verses six and seven speaks about taking all of our anxieties
and bringing them to the Lord in prayer.
Let's get specific with anxieties that we are struggling with
and bring them to the Lord in everything by prayer and supplication, we're told.
So name the concern.
But also he he remembers God's character.
This is what I really want to bear down into here.
So the thing that strengthens David in the midst of his crisis
isn't a kind of strength that he musters up within himself.
It isn't just that he he thinks about some good principles over here and says,
all right, why I have it within myself to be able to cope with what I am facing.
Now, he knows that within himself,
he does not have enough to face life when it becomes overwhelming.
He knows that his own resources will not suffice.
But he finds strength outside of himself in God.
So he says exactly what the problems are.
They are, you see that's those opening verses.
But then he says in verse three, but you, oh, Lord, are.
Here's what they are, my problems, but you are.
So he's not just looking to his own conceptions about God.
He is looking to the God who has revealed his nature to his people in his word.
And he's remembering like this is who God is.
And as I'm looking in God's direction, this is the God I'm looking to.
And I'm calling out to God speaking of his attributes and relying on them.
So notice what he says about God.
Let's get to the specifics.
He says, you, oh, Lord, are a shield about me.
And the shield spoken of here isn't just like a kind of shield in front of you.
That's like a shield that kind of goes all the way around you.
So the idea is he's like he has enemies all around as we've just saw.
But he has this impenetrable shield that is all around him as well.
Well, what is that shield?
It is the Lord, the Lord himself is the shield of his people.
This morning, as we saw in our opening scripture, if you are in Christ,
you are secure.
Nothing can separate us from the love of God in Christ Jesus.
So God is our shield.
He's also our glory.
Notice what he says there in verse three, my glory.
So the taunts of the enemy, like if you're being taunted, how much you feel?
That might cause you to sort of retreat back in shame.
But David doesn't.
He isn't seeking the kind of glory that comes from human admiration.
His eyes are on the glory of the Lord.
And he also remembers that it is the Lord who gives glory, right?
So he says, you are my glory.
So what does he mean by that?
Well, he knows, David knows that whatever others say about him,
he is who the Lord says he is, right?
He belongs to the Lord and it's the Lord who is his glory.
So this ultimate glory belongs to Christ, who is the King, who is exalted above all.
Like, you know, God says of Christ that he is the exalted King
who has dominion over all things.
But at the same time, what is what is true of him also speaks to who we are as well.
So we are God's beloved children.
We are clothed in the perfect righteousness of Christ.
We are seated in heavenly places in him.
This is glorious language being used to describe us.
So what other whatever others say about us?
Let's listen to what the Lord says about us in Christ.
He's our glory.
But also he is the lifter of my head.
Now, I'm no psychologist, but I'm I have heard that a poor like state of state
of mind can also lead to poor posture.
Now, this is the kind of moment where somebody is like, do I sit up or not?
Well, people think, you know, and but it can be the case.
It's not always the case, but that certainly can be so.
But we just know it.
We know that when we are feeling dejected, oftentimes we can embody
what we are feeling as well.
And our bodies will follow with a downcast head and like slouched down
shoulders, but here we see that God is the lifter of our heads.
In other words, he is the source of of encouragement.
But he encourages us.
He gives us this newfound confident outlook that takes encouragement in him.
Right. So so the enemies you taunting, our heads are down, but the Lord says,
no, I am the one who lifts up your head.
Look to me.
So whatever is happening, we can say Romans 8 31, if God is for us,
who can be against us?
Our head is lifted up to him.
So he remembers the Lord's character, but also just notice this about his prayer, too.
He he pleads with confidence.
OK, so he says, verse four, I cried aloud to the Lord
and he answered me from his holy hill.
So he says I cried aloud.
There's a there's an expression of
urgency or urgency and and fervor in what he says.
Right. So the kind of language reflects the urgency of his situation.
He says he's crying out loud to the Lord.
Like imagine him doing that, you know, with the enemies chasing him.
And at the same time, this isn't a totally untethered plea
kind of just thrown out into the darkness.
His earnest, heartfelt plea is expressed with confidence in God at the same time.
It's like, Lord, help me and I'm trusting that you will.
So he's hanging on to the character and promises of God as he cries
aloud to the Lord in the midst of his struggle.
So where's our confidence in prayer found that we can know that the Lord hears
us, we can know that the Lord answers us.
Well, it is found in Christ.
So when we pray at the end of a prayer, you know, in in Jesus' name,
like that's that's not just like signing off like sincerely or at the end
of an email or something like that.
We are we are we are depending on Jesus.
We're saying that it is in and through him that we can come to God with
confidence knowing that he hears and answers our prayers, not because we are
worthy, but because we are in Christ and he gives us access.
So Hebrews chapter four and verse 16 speaks about what Christ has done for us.
But it says that in Christ, we can know that when we come to God's
throne, it is a throne of grace where we will find help in time of need.
All right.
So trusting in God.
So to talk about the crying aloud to the Lord again, doesn't look like
passively sitting back, you know, singing, K sera sera, whatever will be, will be
very old song.
You think shake it off.
You know, it's not just it's not just like I'm just fatalistically
kind of sitting back like this is water on a duck's back.
It's not going to bother me.
So we can be honest like this is really bothering me.
I'm struggling here and I'm continuing in this struggle and I'm bringing
that with honesty to the Lord.
And at the same time, I'm saying, but I want my confidence is in you.
It is in Christ.
I know that you will hear and answer me.
There's that kind of confident expectation in the Lord.
So sometimes confidence looks like struggling with the Lord in prayer.
But also we see that confidence in prayer in Christ can also look like
sleeping as well.
So the struggle is followed by sleep.
So verse five, he says, I laid down and slept.
I woke again for the Lord sustain me.
What's hilarious to me about this is I struggled to get to sleep last night.
I had a I had a nap after the men's hike yesterday.
It was really rough and so I had a quick sleep.
And then about 6 p.m.
I thought I need I need to start getting getting ready, getting in the head space
for tomorrow. And so I made the mistake of drinking a coffee at about 6 p.m.
last night. Terrible decision.
And so I'm thinking worrying about the sermon today and I've got caffeine
pumping through me and I'm laying there.
I cannot go to sleep.
So just keep that in mind as I'm telling you, you can find rest.
You can find sleep.
You think, look at this, you think, especially read second Samuel
15 and 16, how in the world can David find sleep and what he's going through here?
Like he's literally on the run.
Like he's going to find maybe a rock to lay its head on somewhere,
like laying out in the grass, but he can close his eyes and then wake up.
And then he's surrounded by enemies who are going to take his life.
And yet this guy in the most awful situation says I laid down and slept.
So how can David sleep?
Where does he find sleep?
Where does he lay his head?
The answer is the sustaining grace of God.
Right. He can sleep because he knows that the Lord sustains.
Right. So when he talks about the Lord sustaining him, that that's
speaking about God's unceasing, ever active care.
Right. So he can close his eyes in the midst of this awful situation,
knowing that the Lord's eyes are open, so to speak.
He is ever watchful in his care, even when we are in the presence of enemies.
If you go to the Birmingham Museum of Art, there's a really striking
painting called the Liberation of St. Peter.
And it's the depiction of an angel waking Peter up from sleep.
And of course it comes right from Scripture.
If you read in Acts chapter 12, the church has been persecuted.
And one of the apostles, James, has just been has just been killed.
He's just been executed.
And now Peter has been arrested and he is in prison.
And the author, Luke, makes a point to tell us that Peter went to sleep in prison.
I mean, Psalm three could have been, you know, the very Psalm that he was thinking of
and singing, because it's amazing how can he fall asleep there?
And he's got to be woken up by the angel.
And that's how the Lord saves him when the angel kind of leading him out of out of prison.
Even when the angel woke him up, he really had to like strike him on the side,
like really wake him up. He was a deep sleep.
Whatever we are facing, we have an invitation here in this Psalm
and in the rest of Scripture to find rest in Jesus.
So we heard this first last week, it's worth repeating.
So Matthew 11, 28, Jesus says, come to me, all who labor
and are heavy laden, and I will give you rest.
All right. So there's an invitation to rest in God's sovereign care.
And that is found in Jesus.
Now, let me just repeat this.
There are legitimate reasons why people struggle to sleep.
I'm speaking to people with newborns who are here right now.
So this is not a denial of that at all.
But this is an invitation to rest in God's care.
And the path that leads us to resting in God's care is prayer,
the kind of prayer we're reading about here.
And that off and oftentimes the outcome is rest of soul.
Yes, but even actual sleep, right?
The Lord takes us there and sleep is a is a gift that the Lord gives us
for a lot of our lives.
We can thank him for.
And interestingly, there's another kind of sleep that scripture speaks about repeatedly.
It's the sleep of death, right?
Death and sleep are used like interchangeably of each other.
We saw that in John chapter 11 when we looked at Lazarus.
And there are other places actually where resurrection is spoken of as waking up.
It's interesting to read this in light of a light of that language
throughout scripture as well.
Certainly through Jesus, we can trust in God's care,
not only when we lay our head down to sleep at night, but we are
when we were on our very death bed.
We're about to lose everything, so to speak.
We can entrust ourselves to God's care, knowing that in Christ we will not only
sleep, we will rise just as he did.
So that leads us to the kind of the outcome or the prospect that he's
anticipating as he prays this.
Right, so saying, Lord, this is what I'm facing.
So I'm crying out to you in prayer based on who you've revealed yourself to be.
And he prays this with a certain expectation, a hope of what is to come as well.
We see this with a kind of a final prayer in a final statement in song.
So he says, verse seven, a rise, oh, Lord, save me.
Oh, my God.
And that that prayer summarizes really what he's been praying the whole time.
He's drawing it all into a succinct, succinct statement at the end.
Arise, oh, Lord, save me, oh, my God.
But he prays it in the way that he shows that he's expecting
that is exactly what is going to happen.
And the way he communicates that is with really gritty language
that is as awkward as it might be.
I'm really glad scripture includes language like this.
So he says, save me, oh, my God.
But he also says this was to say, for you strike all my enemies on the cheek.
You break the teeth of the wicked.
We're going to read about teeth breaking again in Psalms.
It's it's it's very honest in what it prays.
So what do we do with this?
You know, David could have just said, defeat my enemies.
Why does he go on and use this brutal imagery?
Somebody getting struck on the cheek, even getting their teeth knocked out.
Well, this could be predatory language.
But by that, I mean in Psalm 58,
the same kind of language is used in reference to lion's teeth.
Right. So like a lion on the hunt, looking for its prey,
he's about to sink his teeth in the prey and that is going to kill the prey.
And so David is in a very similar situation there.
So you can imagine that could be the very thing coming to mind
as he's praying or break their teeth.
This could be like the enemies being defanged
and unable to carry out their plots.
So that could be going on here.
But also I think there's a stronger case for this really.
Remember what they're doing at the start.
Remember the kind of where the hardest thing he's facing.
What is it?
It was those taunts that were leaving what their mouths.
They're saying there is no salvation for you in God.
And so he prays at the end, save me.
Oh, my God, the exact opposite of what they were saying.
So you could be rounding this off by saying, Lord, strike them in the very place
that they are speaking these things.
Lord, cause them to cease with their speaking about there being no salvation
in you, because there is salvation.
He expects salvation from God.
So the message is clear, though.
David is praying for salvation against overwhelming odds.
But he's praying knowing that God is more than able to defeat his enemies
and bring about salvation.
Their mouths will be stopped.
And he will be seen and declared to be the savior that he truly is.
There is coming a day when he will execute justice.
David expects that.
We can certainly expect that from the rest of scripture as well.
But what perhaps is more shocking than the language of the Lord striking
his enemies on the cheek is what the Lord allows his enemies to do to him.
John, Chapter 18.
What do we read there?
This same Lord, instead of striking down his enemies, allows his enemies
to strike him on the cheek in John 1822, as Jesus is making his way to the cross.
Here's the message.
While the Lord has every right to strike us down as his enemies,
he came to lay down his life for his enemies.
He willingly received in himself the vengeance that we deserved,
that we instead might be saved.
We might declare the Lord is our salvation so we can cry out in faith,
save me, oh Lord, because.
He loved his enemies, people like us enough to suffer and die in our place.
So now we have this final statement.
It says salvation belongs to the Lord.
Your blessing be on your people.
All right, so salvation doesn't belong to us.
We cannot save ourselves.
It is the Lord alone who saves.
Harsh hardship has a way of reminding us of this as we've seen.
But in the final statement, I want us to really see this.
Notice that he speaks or he moves from just speaking about his own
personal salvation, this is David, just speaking about God's blessing on all his people.
Right, he's been saying, Lord, save me.
But by the end, he's saying, Lord, your blessing be on all your people as you save me.
So this isn't just about his personal safety anymore, but rather the good
of those that he is leading.
In other words, the salvation of the King will overflow in the blessing of his people.
Now think of this in the mouth of Jesus as he prays the Psalms.
Yes, he's going to face death, but after that death is going to be his resurrection
and ascension to his heavenly throne.
What is that going to result in?
It's going to overflow in the blessing of his people, of everyone who trusts in him.
Though Jesus was struck down, he was not defeated.
When he rises from the dead, since his heavenly throne, he does so as
the rightful King who has dominion over all things and is able and ready to bless his people.
So as we cry out to God with our fears, we can do so knowing that he will save
and he will bring us into every blessing that he has promised.
How can we know that?
Because Christ is King, because he reigns over all things.
When he returns, every enemy will be defeated finally.
Everyone who belongs to him, who came and found their rest in him will be saved.
We will live in his blessing forevermore.